[Musik]
das da sind sich ziemlich große masse
und passte und das wird relativ die top
ten auch schöne masken oder sonstigen
optik nicht die blauen augen die blaue
was ich kann habe im gesicht oder die
blaue flagge
kalli flach je nach dem roten kabel muss
immer das ist auch okay das steckt
einfach viel besser dass das make up wie
sollen sie so vor ihm wohl für die
schlechten scherze auch verschiedene
möglichkeiten immer wieder
und warum es ihn zieht bliebe man sich
mal das ist ja in der indirekt hält sich
immerhin mit mir befasst model weiß es
ist schwierig zu schlagen
das ist das phänomen viele fragen sich
und kanada und ocker sonne und wären da
ja und warum sie so landgrebe sind warum
die arbeiten an maschinen
das freitag
mir hat besonders schöne hochzeit habe
mich so gefreut mit der maz am netz
bleiben und der familie gründe und
fußball hat typisch schweizerisch
die idee das ganze daheim sie nochmal
mit dem alzheimer ich eine
schleuserbande perfekte hochzeit sie
eigentlich wunderschön was los
gerade jetzt ist sie brauchen
unternehmen nutzen sagt er ist gerade
vier stunden aus und weiß sicher treiben
und sich nach der geburt die gemeinsame
sohn ein wunschkind
als tochter eines schweizer diplomaten
war konnte auf der halben welt zu hause
ein baby ein ehemann ein eigenheim
die direktionsassistentin schien endlich
angekommen
jesus hat sich von mir das ist so der
studie nach dass sie war ja meine
plötzlich sehe
der arzt habe wirklich kehrt jetzt bitte
geburt verschämt ich denke wenn ich zeit
hatte sich verschenkt mit um ihn kümmere
aber es wird zeit dass ich mir sondern
wir hat das bazl ja mit flussmitte zieht
oder alkoholische großes thema
der schlussgang
das hat mit den abschaum aber ist sie
aber nicht sich die grafik und wochen
einst so verhassten ex spricht vom
spital lavitus wirklich la bekommen ist
aber dass stark alkoholisiert mehr mann
verprügelt gewürgt mit solchen ins
gesicht geschlagen
das ist das über kalte brechen
nasenbeinbruch und so wittich faust ins
gesicht und wie oft sind sie dann im
später sie wenig an nur sieben mal nicht
so schlimm
den ersten spieltag ist schlimm ist sie
dank sowie java china das land kämpft
wenn in nizza und krampft hat was mir so
ausgeartet war
wenn die ferien gegangen war war sowie
körperlich bbb ist immer schlimmer
werden und eines geortet
der sohn ist mittlerweile ein teenager
auf seinen wunsch hin wird in diesem
film nicht näher auf seine situation
eingegangen
nach zwölf jahren ihr hölle gelernt core
i tät der ausstieg zusammen mit ihrem
sohn flüchtete sich ins frauenhaus wir
treffen die damalige leiterin zum schutz
werden an dieser stelle wieder das
frauenhaus noch die mitarbeiterinnen
gezeigt hätte man auch durch immer
gefragt sind sie unmittelbar in gefahr
und daran ist ja eigentlich nie das
schlafe jetzt bereich software liegt im
bett alle zwei wochen stirbt in der
schweiz eine person infolge häuslicher
gewalt die meisten davon sind frauen im
letzten jahr registrierte die polizei
rund 17.000 straftaten im bereich
partnerschaftlicher oder familiäre
beziehungen
doch noch immer holt ein großteil der
betroffenen keine hilfe von außen
es ist eine große schar mumme von den
betroffenen von den opfern von
häuslicher gewalt darüber zu reden
hallo ja weil es es ist beschämend dass
einem selber das passiert es man hat es
gerade auch frauen wie fragt wie das nie
im leben in ihrem sag ich jetzt mal
jemals den gedanken gehabt hätte dass
ihr das passieren könnte
ich habe staatsanwältin als klienten
gehabt ich habe ärztinnen psychologinnen
alles politikerinnen haben doch nie
geglaubt dass ihnen das passieren könnte
und sie sind gerade auch wenn sie dann
nicht gleich sofort gegangen sind wenn
das wie eine längere zeit gedauert hat
bis sie sich daraus haben befreien
können ist das unglaublich beschämend
dass man das mit sich machen lassen und
ja nicht an sich will
[Musik]
die perfekte familie vor zeigen ob haben
wir davor zeigte dürftigkeit oder sich
seine mechanismus wo man will zeigen
dass alles in ordnung sei ja nicht als
versager stark es so viel nicht versagt
warum gönnt franken
das ist natürlich eine sehr komplexe
frage es gibt ganz verschiedene gründe
in erster linie ist es oft so also in
erster linie ist es eigentlich so dass
die frauen ja den mann geheiratet haben
oder mit ihm zusammen sind weil sie ihn
lieben also das heißt wir haben eine
emotionale ebene drin und es ist dann so
unfassbar dass es so kippt und es ist
dann schon der versuch und das hoffen es
könnte wieder gut kommen und immer
wieder dieses eigentlich will ich ja
nicht mich trennen sondern ich will
eigentlich dass die gewalt aufhört es
dauert lange bis sie realisieren sie
können es gar nicht verhindern
es passiert irgendwann dass frauen das
für sich annehmen dass dieses ja ich
habe schon wenn ich das nicht gemacht
hätte und wenn ich das nicht gesagt
hätte dann dann wäre er nicht so
explodiert also dass sie bereit sind
eigentlich auch wie in teil zur minister
schuld auf sich zu nehmen weil dann hat
man wenigstens noch ein bisschen
kontrolle über die situation
[Musik]
[Applaus]
was löst die bilder ansieht je zuvor
geht es ganz klar ist das was das nicht
das macht mit seinem 18 ich glaube sie
haben es gemacht und das ist etwas wo
man durch obwohl es warum warum die so
was ich trage der dauernd monat noch in
dieser woche auch für ihn war es eine
liebeshochzeit unerklärlich wie die
anfängliche zuneigung schleichend zur
gewalt wurde ausartete bis korrekt ihren
mann nach einer brutalen prügelattacke
schließlich bei der polizei anzeigte
ihr mann besuchte daraufhin ein gewalt
programm
diese maßnahme vermochte die beziehung
aber auch nicht mehr zu retten und nur
ist heute so geblieben jetzt startet und
wasseranschluss umsatz wieder spürbar
sein held weil es viel wert ist ganz
bewusst wollen immer mehr und immer mehr
ab dass ich nichts problems plänen
müssten einfach wenn dir die ganze nacht
terrorisiert waren bis am morgen früh
bis zum pc nämlich aber ich sehe nicht
dass frauen 200 vorstände erlebt und in
der heimat sonntag im hinterland alles
nachvollziehen was war sie nein
vorgeordnet und da zieht es ist nur
damit sie ihre hauptforderung rangiere
aber es gibt auch grenzen
lucio bestreitet oder ob er über schloss
das die ganze stadt mitteilte
das problem ist und alles andere bleibt
das alter wo ich nicht und ein rohr ich
sehe ich eine tätlichkeit
apropos bald gut aber das heißt nicht
dass sie auch hätte die frau bis zum
nasenbeinbruch zum beispiel ist da wäre
sie gegenüber ihrem übergriff leicht
wird also körperliche qual man natürlich
normal ist trickreich natürlich auch
nervlich geschichte
viele software bett ist sie nicht
verlassen
das nicht machen schüttelt opel zu
streichen hat sollte vielleicht mich
wäre aber da war
das hat verheerende folgen für herren
die folge fast vier jahre sind nun
vergangen seit konnte sich von ihrem
land trennte
die scheidung ist noch immer nicht
vollzogen heute steht ein weiterer
gerichtstermin an
ihre nachbarn warnen
ich sehe nicht wo ich locker wurde
passen
die anzeige gegen ihren mann wegen
körperverletzung und drohung hat
kommentiert zurückgezogen was sie im
nachhinein bitter bereut
in diesen tagen stimmte der nationalrat
einer gesetzesverschärfung zu neu sollen
opfer von beziehungsgewalt nicht mehr
allein bestimmen ob die anzeige
zurückgezogen werden kann
für conti kommt diese regelung zu spät
dann findet sie gut dass über extremes
bestehendes ob die opfer schüttete
verfassung nach dem erlebnis klar urteil
urteile zu können
das ist einfach nicht möglich abhängig
in der abhängigkeit und sie hat ja dann
pro tag zurück zog mehrere gründe
laut schlosser und alles um doch noch
eine chance
seit der trennung verkehrt komitee mit
ihrem ehemann nur noch schriftlich dass
ihm heute zum ersten mal wieder begegnen
wird belastet sie sehr
ja das stimmt hätte ich hatte es
verschiedene töne
ich hab das nicht vertragen
man ist nicht alleine wie vor
ok bis später
nur in begleitung ihres anwalts schaffte
scoring t an den verhandlungstisch
wieder wird gestritten um das sorgerecht
und um den verkauf des gemeinsamen
hauses eine einigung und somit eine
baldige scheidung liegt in weiter ferne
das ist ja vor gut drei jahren lernte
corinth ihren heutigen partner kennen im
internet
erich z ist polizist bilder der gewalt
kennt er zwar von seiner arbeit was es
aber konkret heißt mit einer frau eine
beziehung zu führen die geprügelt und
gedemütigt wurde ist auch für ihn neu
und dementsprechend war der start
schwierig am anfang ist einfach dass der
vertrauensaufbau sehr schwierig sie
jeder das glauben machen das ist
eigentlich nicht böse närrinnen der
schweine und eigentlich aber besucher
war nicht vom ihm lange zusammen sie ja
dann einfach das passiert das bedürfnis
sami k und immer noch das meist
einfacher bis willkürlich die zu ihrem
labor bis ist passiert was ich normal
großer bis der führer ist ja nicht damit
auseinander so dass das ewz touran also
kein grab des michelbacher parallel
werde
das ist ja gar nicht möglich ja wenn man
immer der gedanke ja mit war der teufel
los
und dann merke ich gar
er wird am liebsten betty anne waters
danken sondern schöne ort des 40
für ihr ziel und das heißt für die 24
jahre alte tier in halver irgendwie das
verarbeiten das märchen die irgendwie
naja war und dass auch die hintergrund
stellen so langsam wie märkte sind
belästige stück bezieht immer das thema
abschließen der abschließt aber es ist
ja
sie werde zumal abschlüsse ja also ich
vergesse von isny wird immer ein teil
von mir
lebenslänglich
[Musik]
frauen so zurecht wie ist das möglich
dass begriffe gibt ihre griffe aber was
manchmal nicht versteht sich einfach
nicht gegangen werde ich für ihn
unerklärlich für ihn als andersartig
schlimmste fragen gestellt aber warum
das tut mir richtig weh heute aber das
ist vergangenheit gemacht aber es gibt
einfach durch zwölf jahren am schluss 2
zeigt sich zu mir und ich hab hier ist
am boden zerstört mache schmerz alles
und schüttelt hoffen sei kein verlust
und dann geht's weiter zum schluss
packte sie zum telefon gegangen witz und
frauen sagen
johnstons note 2 welt denn für mich ist
sehr klar wollte
das sind ja
und es standen zur energie market 2 wird
sich natürlich brandsatz über die jahre
aber am schluss 52 wird
da gibt es wie gesagt